لا متغير على المشهد في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا معارك متواصله اخذه في التصاعد
ميدانها دونيتسك بالتزامن مع مرور تسع
سنوات على اول معركه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والموالين لروسيا كيف تتهم
موسكو بتنفيذ هجمات استهدفت منشات بنيه
تحتيه كسد كارليفكا قرب دونيتسكو وبقتل
مدنيين في دينيبرو جنوب شرقي البلاد اما
روسيا فتحدثت عن قصف اوكراني طال منطقتين
داخل اراضيها الجنوبيه في غضون ذلك اعلن
مالك شركه فاجنر الروسيه
تكليف قواته بالدخول الى جبهه جديده غير
باخمه للقيام بما سماها مهمه الدفاع عن
الوطن
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا نبدا
بالخبر العاجل اذا اعلنت السلطات المحليه
في دونتسك المواليه لروسيا استهداف القوات
الاوكرانيه لماريو في البصاروخين بعيدي
المدى للمزيد تنضم الينا من دوناتسك
مراسله الجزيره كارمن جوخادار والمزيد من
التفاصيل اليك الكلمه ما الذي حدث تحديدا
نعم قبل قليل قبل دقائق اعلنت السلطات
المحليه عن استهداف محيط مصنع ازوفستال
بصاروخين بعيدى في مدينه مريوبل هذا
الاستهداف ليس الاول في الايام الماضيه
وفي التاسع عشر من ايار مايو تم استهداف
ماريوبل عشيه الذكرى الاولى لسيطره القوات
الروسيه على هذه المدينه نذكر جيدا ان
لازوستار رمزيه كبيره لناحيه المعارك
الضاريه التي خيضت للسيطره على هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد من مريوبل اذ انها تشكل
ان هذا المصنع كان يشكل العائق الاخير في
حينها لسيطره القوات الروسيه على مدينه
ماريوبل الاستراتيجيه لناحيه انها تطل على
البحر الاسود ولنحيه انها تشكل امتدادا
للقوات الروسيه واستمرارا لناحيه من
الناحيه الجغرافيه حتى الوصول الى شبه
جزيره قبل قليل تحدثتم عن هذه الذكرى
بالنسبه لاهالي دنيا الذين اليوم عاشوا
قصفا اوكرانيا مكثفا قبل قليل ايضا اعلنت
السلطات المحليه انه من التاسعه صباحا
وحتى التاسعه بعد مساء تم قصف مدينه
دانياتس باكثر من 100 قذيفه احدى هذه
الاهداف كانت معهد البحوث العلميه هذا
المعهد الذي لحق به ضرر كبير نحن كنا قد
زرنا هذا موقع القصف هذا وافادت السلطات
عن مقتل شخص وجرح عدد من الاشخاص الاخرين
ايضا اليوم هذا القصف المركز في هذه
الذكره بالنسبه لاهالي دانياتك خلف كثيرا
من الاضرار في المباني السكنيه وفي
المقتنيات بالنسبه للاهالي عدد كبير من
المباني السكنيه محطه للقطارات ايضا في
دنيتك تم قصفها خلال اليوم عينا بعض من
هذه الاضرار والاهالي طبعا تحدثوا عن
خسائرهم الكبيره على مدى ليس فقط في هذا
القصف اليوم ولكن على مدى الاعوام التسعه
على امتداد هذه المعارك المشتده ايضا
تفصيل اليوم فيما خص افديفكا ومقاله اف
جيلي بريجوجن عن انه سيكون لقواته جبهه
جديده من المحتمل ان تكون احدى هذه
الجبهات التي من الممكن ان تكون قوات
فاجنر فيها في المرحله المقبله هذا
التفصيل ايضا مرتبط بتفجير احد السدود عند
نهر كارلوس شكرا جزيلا لك على